[Música]
hola bienvenidos a kobe 19 la semana en
américa soy santiago lópez gonzález este
es el espacio de france 24 en el que
hacemos un resumen de las noticias más
destacadas relacionadas con la pandemia
del cob el 19 a continuación les
presento los temas que tenemos para el
programa de hoy después de conocer los
resultados de su investigación y también
de estudios en varios pacientes la
prestigiosa revista médica the lancet
destacó la eficacia de la vacuna rusa
sputnik ve con cerca del 90 y 1.6 por
ciento de efectividad les vamos a dar
detalles de ella y con nuestro asesor
científico el doctor pérez conversaremos
sobre esta opción de inmunización contra
el joven 19 también destacamos hoy chile
ha puesto en marcha su plan de
vacunación a escala nacional llegando a
varias regiones del país incluida la
remota isla de pascua más de 280 mil
personas ya han sido inmunizadas en ese
país con nuestra corresponsal patricia
luna conoceremos los detalles de este
plan los avances y la expectativa que
tiene el gobierno en su implementación y
finalmente iremos hasta uruguay este
país anunció la reapertura de sus
fronteras
después de varios meses con un acceso
restringido el gobierno de la republica
oriental también anunció la compra de
varios lotes de vacunas así como dio a
conocer también detalles de cómo será
ese plan de vacunación en uno de los
países que mejor ha conseguido sortear
esta emergencia sanitaria mundial
tenemos los detalles con nuestra
corresponsal karina dalmás pues son
algunos de los temas comencemos de
inmediato pasamos entonces a la noticia
central que es la noticia de la semana
que la protagonizó la vacuna sputnik ve
que se convierte en otra alternativa
para los planes de inmunización a nivel
mundial contra el kobe 19 y está ya a la
par de algunas vacunas desarrolladas por
otros laboratorios a nivel internacional
argentina por ejemplo ya ha inmunizado a
más de 297 mil personas con esta vacuna
rusa
bolivia también ha vacunado a cerca de
3500 personas con las pugnas de mexico
también ya anunció la compra de unos 24
millones de dosis están negociando
todavía con el gobierno ruso y panamá
también ya se mostró interesado en
adquirir unas 3 millones de dosis
vamos a ver algunas de las
características de esta vacuna la
sputnik bay fue desarrollada por el
centro nacional de epidemiología y
microbiología gamma leia en rusia tiene
una eficacia como les decía del 90 y 1.6
por ciento es de vector viral ya vamos a
ver con nuestro invitado qué significa
ser de vector viral tiene mínimos
efectos secundarios ha demostrado ser
muy eficaz entre los mayores de 60 años
y tiene protección contra las formas
moderadas y también las formas severas
del cobi 19 requiere dos dosis la
segunda de ellas tiene que ser 21 días
después de la primera y su
almacenamiento en frío es mucho más
sencillo que la de facer solamente
requiere entre 2 a 8 grados centígrados
una dosis vale solamente 10 dólares
estos son datos publicados por the
lancet y por el fondo ruso de
inversiones directas que es la encargada
de financiar esta investigación a nivel
internacional
vamos entonces a analizar este tema con
el doctor carlos eduardo pérez asesor
científico de france24 infectólogo de la
universidad nacional de colombia
un saludo doctor como siempre es un
gusto tenerlo con nosotros aquí en
france 24 y como recibe la comunidad
médica y también la comunidad científica
este aval o este artículo positivo en
torno a la spot de una vacuna que al
principio de la pandemia generó todo
tipo de controversias a nivel político y
médico también
y una de las cosas importantes es que lo
primero que supimos fue por notas de
prensa y no por estudios científicos
sino fue el desarrollo de la vacuna que
la vacuna era efectiva pero los estudios
clínicos que es donde los científicos
buscan los datos no los teníamos
disponibles yo creo que eso creó un poco
de incertidumbre sin embargo rusia se ha
reconocido como un país pionero en el
desarrollo de vacunas sobre todos de
estas de vector viral
desde hace muchos años y cuando salen
los datos son muy robustos son bastante
bien diseñadas los estudios entonces sea
ese paso y ese aval que esperamos todos
en los estudios publicados doctor pérez
qué ventajas tiene entonces esta vacuna
al sputnik ve por encima de las otras
que ya están en el mercado que incluso
ya están siendo inoculadas en personas
alrededor del mundo
digamos que en general las vacunas todas
han sido muy buenas noticias por dos
cosas uno ningún paciente ha fallecido
en mí por la vacuna ni a consecuencia el
coi 19 cualquiera sea la marca la vacuna
esta vacuna del coi de de coke del
sputnik él tiene una ventaja que sus
estudios de eficacia son del 91 por
ciento contrario a las otras de héctor
vidal como las de astrazéneca y las de
janssen que están entre el 60 y el 90
por ciento los datos muestran una
efectiva de 90 más con más de 90 por
ciento lo cual lo hace muy interesante
una alternativa que es disponible y
accesible económica y también con buenos
estudios clínicos pero clave recordar
todas las vacunas protegen contra el
coaching severo y evitan la mortalidad
en un 100 por ciento todas las marcas de
las vacunas doctor en la introducción
estaba dando varios datos particulares
de esta vacuna rusa que significa que
sea de vector viral sé que esto es un
término médico científico porque debe
ser en dos dosis y algunas personas nos
preguntaban que si entre
una dosis y otra existe el riesgo que la
persona contraiga el cubil 19
el vector viral hace relación a que los
virus este virus adenovirus es un virus
que conocemos desde hace muchos años
estos virus no son patógenos es decir
que nosotros no los vinculamos y no nos
produce enfermedad utilizamos este virus
como un vector como un transportador se
inocula el dna que va a producir la
proteína y esa proteína es la que va a
generar las defensas para el sistema
inmunológico
eso se llama vector viral estas vacunas
requieren dos dosis porque en la primera
dosis se hace una primera respuesta
inmunológica y luego se refuerza esa
respuesta inmunológica con nuevamente
retando con el antígeno con la partícula
viral entre las dos dosis todavía la
respuesta inmune no es completa por eso
puede ser susceptible y es importante
mantener las medidas de bioseguridad
todo el tiempo hasta que se culmine
completamente la vacunación se calcula
que después de la segunda semana de la
segunda inoculación de la inmunidad es
completo doctor yo me salgo un poco del
tema pero quiero aprovechar esta
conexión para preguntar por otro tema
que fue destacado
en diferentes medios internacionales a
lo largo de esta semana y es ese
desarrollo que están haciendo algunos
médicos y científicos en israel de un
medicamento que aparentemente por lo
menos en 30 personas ya ha sido probado
que ha sanado a estas personas que ya
estaban padeciendo con 1.019 incluso
estaban hospitalizadas para ser
atendidas allí porque eran un kobe 19
agresivo quien sabe al respecto podemos
empezar a confiar también en
medicamentos y tener esto como una
alternativa a la vacunación y también al
autocuidado
claro no solamente son estos hay varios
grupos de medicamentos orales que están
en estudio es crítico estamos esperando
los resultados lo que hay en israel es
un tratamiento tópico local que hace que
controle el virus y que ha hecho
efectiva en un grupo pequeño el paciente
realmente de 30 con muy reducido pero
como los resultados han sido tan
alentadores se plantean estos cinco ya a
gran escala con este tipo de
medicamentos cosas similares suceden en
alemania en el reino unido en eeuu donde
se están desarrollando medicamentos casi
todos orales que pueden controlar el cod
y yo creo que vamos bien
la vacunación las opciones terapéuticas
pero debemos mantener el autocuidado
porque es la esencia y es la mejor
vacuna que tenemos hoy doctor pérez como
siempre muchas gracias por estar
recomendaciones el autocuidado es la
base central de esta protección contra
el cob y 19 muchas gracias por
acompañarnos y explicarnos en palabras
muy simples todos estos temas
científicos y médicos muchas gracias
hablamos ahora de mexico que emitió una
autorización para el uso de emergencia
de esta vacuna del sputnik b
mismo las autoridades mexicanas también
indicaron que firmaron un contrato para
recibir un primer lote de dosis a partir
de este mes de febrero vamos a conocer
más detalles de la situación allí en
mexico y para profundizar en detalles
hablamos con mario' carbonell nuestro
corresponsal en ciudad de méxico hola
mario ya lo estábamos diciendo méxico
compró algunas dosis de esta vacuna
sputnik que más detalle se sabe de esta
transacción de esta compra cuál va a ser
el plan de vacunación para estas dosis
cómo está avanzando el plan de
vacunación que ya está en marcha en este
país
pues fueron días de polémica luego de
que se anunció el acuerdo de compra
precisamente de esta vacuna de sputnik
cuando aún no se conocían los resultados
de la fase 3 de ensayos clínicos
posteriormente bueno ya se publicaron en
la revista the lancet y la comisión
federal para la protección contra
riesgos sanitarios la cofepris que es la
entidad reguladora dio su autorización
para el uso de emergencia de esta vacuna
y el secretario de salud jorge alcocer
firmó el contrato de compra este se
envió a rusia y se está a la espera de
que las autoridades rusas hagan lo
propio y será hasta entonces cuando se
cuente con una tabla de fechas de
entrega a detalle esto pues ha generado
inquietud incluso entre los gobernadores
del país que este jueves pidieron a la
federación que les dé ya un calendario
de fechas de entrega para que puedan
completar los esquemas de vacunación al
personal de la salud en sus estados y el
subsecretario hugo lópez gatell le
respondió simplemente que las dosis van
a llegar que la vacunación
a efectivo pero no se sabe hoy por hoy
cuándo van a llegar el salario también
lo hicimos seguimiento a lo largo de la
semana al estado de salud del presidente
andrés manuel lópez obrador que es lo
último el día dijo que se estaba
sintiendo mejor pero que lo último que
se sabe sobre el mandatario
pues la salud del presidente va mejor e
incluso lópez obrador este jueves subió
un vídeo a sus redes sociales el segundo
vídeo que publica desde que contrajo la
enfermedad para dar a conocer que se
aplicó la prueba de antígeno y ya dio
negativo asarco 2 digo sentirse bien
incluso hizo un recorrido a pie por los
pasillos y las escalinatas de palacio
nacional para demostrar su condición
física sin embargo dijo que guardara
todavía un tiempo de reposo para
recuperarse al 100% y eso sí aprovechó
este mensaje para decirse optimista no
nada más en cuanto a su estado de salud
sino respecto de la situación del país
en general presumió algunos datos de
creación de empleo al arranque del año
de aumento en el consumo en tiendas de
autoservicio y dijo que pues esta
pandemia ha hecho a los mexicanos más
fraternos más solidarios y que vamos a
salir adelante el subsecretario lópez
gatell dijo que ya se encuentra
asintomático pero que continuará la
vigilancia médica en espera de que
pronto sea
en sus labores todo indica que el
mandatario se está recuperando rápido
del cob y 19 mario actualizamos entonces
cómo está la situación allí en torno a
contagiados víctimas mortales del cob y
19 el plan de vacunación ya sabemos que
está avanzando y cuáles son las
restricciones que se mantienen en firme
todavía para la población
pues el plan de vacunación está
estancado se han aplicado 675 mil dosis
de la vacuna de facer pero como sabemos
se interrumpieron los envíos de estas
vacunas y aunque se tienen contratos de
compra con los laboratorios astrazéneca
cancino y la sputnik pues ninguna de
estas ha llegado al país por lo que a
pesar de que reiteró el propio
presidente las metas de vacunación por
ejemplo marzo febrero y marzo para todos
los adultos mayores lo cierto es que
mientras no lleguen las dosis pues
podrían verse comprometidos estos
objetivos mientras tanto el gobierno
federal lanzó un sitio web para que los
ancianos o sus familiares se registren
para decir que quieren la vacuna que
pongan sus datos dirección teléfono
correo electrónico clave poblacional
pero el problema es que a los 30 minutos
de que lanzó el gobierno esta página se
cayó las autoridades alegan que hubo
saturación que le tendrían que dar
mantenimiento lo cierto es que duró 2
días
sin funcionar y ahora pues funciona pero
de manera intermitente lo que ha causado
pues una ola de críticas esto mientras
el país continúa con altos índices de
muertes y contagios este jueves fue el
cuarto día con el mayor número de
muertos reportados en un lapso de 24
horas en lo que va de la pandemia habría
muchas gracias y pues muy atentos
entonces al desarrollo de este plan de
vacunación allí en mexico
muchas gracias por esta información
desde la capital mexicana pasamos un
poco más al sur nos vamos ahora hasta
nicaragua la ausencia de medidas
oficiales para hacer frente a la
pandemia y también el hecho de que los
ciudadanos ya se han relajado un poco
permiten a tener allí actividades en las
calles algunas de ellas por supuesto
llevan a las aglomeraciones en donde
puede haber contagios potenciales los
médicos nicaragüenses son los únicos que
están alertando de una nueva ola de
contagio de kobe 19 que puede saturar el
sistema de salud de ese país
centroamericano veamos
envidian va al sur de nicaragua ni una
pandemia puede interrumpir las fiestas
patronales cada año centenares festejan
a san sebastián con un colorido atuendo
que representa el mestizaje ahora con
tapabocas incluidos
primeramente hay menos personas por el
miedo
por el miedo prácticamente y pues
tenemos que estar ocupando mascarillas
el uso del alcohol a cada rato y este
año no todos los bailantes podemos
entrar a la basílica
[Música]
marlon flores es el líder de este grupo
de más de 100 bailarines geli al igual
que el resto de tradicionalistas
participan para seguir un legado
familiar por cumplir una promesa de fe
el pueblo deberían bueno un pueblo fele
un pueblo que le rinde mucho fervor al
patrón san sebastián entonces pues hemos
venido adecuando no y tomando las
medidas sanitarias para poder celebrar
estas festividades de san sebastián en
la iglesia el exceso es limitado pero en
las afueras la municipalidad montó
tarimas y bailes para que las personas
festejan bajo una peligrosa normalidad
que se vive desde que llegó la pandemia
y que ha sido criticada por médicos
independientes es evidente que ya
estamos en lo que llamaríamos la segunda
ola apenas estamos digamos en la subida
hacia
en lo que es esta segunda ola no sabemos
si va a ser tan grande como la primera o
más pequeña no lo sabemos todavía pero
si estamos claro de que esto ha sido
determinado por las enumeraciones que se
han dado antes porque en el país hay una
falsa seguridad de control del virus del
cual no se ha hecho las autoridades
registran desde el inicio de la pandemia
168 fallecidos por kobe mientras
sociedad civil denuncia que las cifras
reales rondan los 3.000 fallecidos en
nicaragua nunca se ordenó ningún tipo de
confinamiento en cambio festejos como
estos son promovidos constantemente
a continuación demos un vistazo al
avance de la vacunación en américa
latina' al cierre de esta semana así es
como están las cifras en orden
alfabético argentina lleva más de 297
mil dosis aplicadas brasil más de 3
millones 73 mil dosis mientras que
bolivia que solamente lleva una semana
inoculando a sus habitantes ya supera
las 3 mil 500 dosis chile por su parte
ya supera las 287 mil 300 dosis costa
rica en centroamérica ya aplicó más de
45 mil 563 dosis ecuador supera las 6
mil 200 dosis mientras que méxico ha
inyectado más de 634 mil dosis para más
tierra entonces esta semana con 6 mil
400 dosis solamente 8 países en la
región están avanzando en planes de
inmunización contra el kobe 19
y mientras tanto cuba avanza también en
su fase de investigación y de una del
desarrollo de una posible vacuna para
comprobar su efectividad y también los
posibles efectos secundarios centenares
de personas se han inscrito como
voluntarios para recibir una dosis de
esta vacuna que recibe el nombre de
soberana 1 y soberana 2 cuba es el único
país de américa latina que está
estudiando y desarrollando una vacuna
contra el kobe 19 a partir de sus
propios estudios bajo la autorización de
la o ms
si demuestra ser efectiva cuba inmunizar
y a al total de la población de la isla
a lo largo del 2021
abdalá es el nombre de una de las cuatro
vacunas hechas en cuba producto
desarrollado por el centro de
investigación gubernamental
el fármaco se inoculó por primera vez en
humanos este 2 de febrero 760
voluntarios entre los cuales se
encuentran personas con enfermedades
crónicas recibirán la potencial vacuna
en lo menos que puedo hacer
brindarle un apoyo para para ver si
logramos que esta vacuna tenga su éxito
abdalá es una de las 4 vacunas
desarrolladas por cuba dos de ellas se
encuentran en una fase de desarrollo
intermedia mientras que otra todavía
está en un momento inicial de la
investigación cuba es el único país de
américa latina que tiene vacunas propias
en estudios reconocidos por la
organización mundial de la salud el
gobierno estima tener una capacidad de
producción de 100 millones de dosis a lo
largo de 2021 así tendría de sobras para
inmunizar a toda su población sin
depender de fármacos producidos en el
exterior
cuba podría solicitar
un permiso una autorización de uso
emergencia
a finales de mayo eso le permitiría a
cuba comenzar a vacunar a los grupos
prioritarios durante el segundo
trimestre de 2021
la isla necesita este fármaco
especialmente después de un fuerte
repunte de casos tras reabrir sus
fronteras este enero se registró el
número de contagios y de víctimas
mortales más altos en 10 meses para un
total de cerca de 28 mil casos y 218
víctimas mortales recapitulemos veamos
cuáles son las vacunas que están en el
mercado debidamente aprobadas y que ya
han sido inoculadas en diferente medida
en la población mundial hay 6 vacunas
disponibles en este momento les voy a
mencionar a partir de la que tiene mayor
eficacia contra el joven 19 la vacuna de
facer variante que es una n mensajero y
tiene 95 por ciento de eficacia requiere
dos dosis y estará almacenada a menos 70
grados centígrados
la vacuna de moderna también es de aire
en el mensajero tiene 94 por ciento de
eficacia y debe ser refrigerada a menos
20 grados centígrados sigue la sputnik
que ya les habíamos dado algunos de los
detalles importantes y destacados de
esta vacuna le sigue las vacunas
desarrolladas en china el asesino farm o
la corona back desde la farmacéutica
sinovac
tiene 79 de efectividad la segunda en
algunos casos va del 50% al 100% tiene
unas variaciones ambas requieren estar
entre 2 a 8 grados centígrados en
refrigeración
finalmente la vacuna oxford astrazéneca
es de vector viral tiene 60 por ciento
de efectividad y puede estar almacenada
entre 2 y 8 grados centígrados son las
vacunas que están en este momento
disponibles
y chile también puso en marcha su plan
masivo de vacunación contra el cob y 19
en una primera fase habíamos hablado que
estaban inoculando al personal de salud
ahora otros sectores de la sociedad
chilena incluso en la remota isla de paz
con el pacífico ya recibieron dosis para
inocular a los locales chile ha recibido
dosis de la vacuna desarrollada por
facer variante que también de la vacuna
de sinovac el presidente de chile
sebastián piñera daba detalles sobre
este plan de vacunación escuchemos nunca
antes chile había enfrentado un desafío
como éste lo que más habíamos logrado
vacunar eran 8 millones de los ahora nos
hemos propuesto duplicar prácticamente
también está lo cual con el aporte con
la colaboración con el compromiso de
todos estoy seguro lo vamos a lograr
vamos a conocer detalles con patricia
luna la corresponsal de france 24 en
santiago ella nos da más información
desde uno de los puntos de vacunación en
el liceo carmela carvajal en providencia
en santiago la capital en patricia cuál
es el balance de esta puesta en marcha
de este plan de vacunación en estos
primeros días en los que ha avanzado
cuéntanos
hola santiago nos encontramos en uno de
los 1400 centros de vacunación que
existen en todo chile que se encuentra
en este momento cerrado recordemos que
la vacunación oficialmente se inició en
el país el pasado 24 de diciembre con la
llegada de las primeras dosis de la
vacuna de facer sin embargo como ha
ocurrido en otros países del mundo esta
vacuna ha llegado con cuentagotas
también a chile y las primeras dosis
fueron destinadas a trabajadores de la
salud de unidades de cuidados intensivos
fue la llegada de 4 millones de dosis de
bala la vacuna china sinovac en la
última semana de enero la que permitió
al gobierno avanzar con este plan de
vacunación masiva que se iniciaba el
miércoles de manera muy exitosa
superando la cifra de 100.000 vacunados
al día que se había fijado el gobierno
son casi medio millón de chilenos los
que ya han sido vacunados para cumplir
el ambicioso plan del gobierno de
vacunar a los 5 millones de población
más vulnerables pues está en los tres
primeros meses desde 2021 y a 15
millones de los 19 millones de chilenos
en los seis primeros meses del año
patricia usted lo decía es un plan muy
ambicioso que es lo que sigue entonces
en este plan de vacunación en términos
de llegadas
los lotes de vacunas más regiones del
país abarca dos diferentes sectores o
estratos de la sociedad chilena
así es la vacunación comenzaba el
miércoles con las personas mayores de 90
años ha ido en orden de edad regresiva
hoy se vacunaban los de 86 85 años y la
próxima semana lo hará a las personas de
20 85 y 70 años de edad cada día tiene
alojado una cifra de una edad diferente
y junto a ellos se vacuna también el
resto del personal sanitario de las
fuerzas armadas y de carabineros en sus
propias instituciones también alumnos en
prácticas de medicina y junto a ellos
trabajadores y residentes tanto de los
centros de residencias de ancianos como
de la red de orfanatos públicas en el
servicio nacional de menores que
constituyen la población más vulnerable
definida en un principio por el gobierno
a partir de ahí se avanzará al resto de
la población todo ha transcurrido de
manera fluida organizada coordinada tan
solo se registraban con las de una hora
de espera en el estadio de la florida en
uno de los barrios más populares de
santiago y también algunos problemas en
los vacunatorios de viña del mar donde
no había dosis suficientes para la
cantidad de personas que se presentaron
a vacunarse salvo esos accidentes
incidentes aislados todo ha funcionado
de manera coordinada y fluida por el
momento patricia recordemos cómo está el
país porque la lucha contra el coi 19
sigue sigue habiendo contagio sigue
habiendo personas fallecidas
las cifras parecen ser bastante
auspiciosa santiago por lo que dicen en
su último informe el ministerio de salud
las autoridades que establecen que la
última semana los casos descendieron en
un 12% en todo el país y en 13 de las 16
regiones sin embargo preocupa el alza de
casos en la región de los ríos que
tienen la mayor incidencia de todos y
también en coquimbo calama y maule todas
ellas regiones turísticas donde acuden a
veranear los chilenos esto en relación a
un permiso de vacaciones que concedió el
gobierno del que se han entregado más de
un millón setecientos mil permisos y que
permitiría los viajes inter regionales
lo que habría hecho un poco que subieran
los casos en estos lugares de veraneo
tradicionales para los chilenos las
autoridades revisen ahora si este
permiso se va a mantener o no y fue
otorgado argumentando razones de salud
mental que ha sido muy necesaria para
todos en este año gracias.patricia por
este reporte desde la ciudad de santiago
en chile nos vamos ahora hasta la
amazonía en brasil allí comenzó también
el plan de vacunación que dio prioridad
a las zonas rurales en la selva muy
lejanas
a los grandes centros urbanos de esta
región brasileña la región amazónica es
el punto de origen de una de las nuevas
variantes de kobe 19 que puso en alerta
al mundo entero
las comunidades remotas del estado de
amazonas en brasil recibieron con júbilo
la llegada de las primeras vacunas
contra el cob y 19 de la empresa astra
zéneca trabajadores de la salud viajaron
hasta allí para inmunizar a decenas de
adultos mayores que viven en las zonas
rurales la prioridad son los que pasan
de 80 años y los indígenas de unas 265
aldeas en la región
estoy muy feliz porque es lo que
esperaba y espero que todo salga bien
la amazonía tiene la tasa de mortalidad
por coronavirus más alta de todo el país
y es además el lugar donde surgió la
variante brasileña de kobe 19 que
comparte algunas características con
otras variantes del reino unido y
sudáfrica y que se cree son más
contagiosas a esto se suma una segunda
ola de contagios que ha colapsado el
sistema de salud tenemos que saber que
hemos perdido a tantos ancianos y
jóvenes
esta es una esperanza de que las cosas
van a cambiar y a mejorar
la situación preocupa a los países
vecinos ante la escasez de oxígeno el
presidente venezolano dijo que enviaría
camiones cargados hacia los estados
brasileños de roraima y amazonas
fronterizos con venezuela adicionales a
los enviados a mediados de enero las
autoridades colombianas también por lo
expuestas que se ven las comunidades
indígenas que viven en las periferias de
leticia donde ya se han confirmado casos
de la nueva variante
y rápidamente nos vamos hasta uruguay un
país en donde hay varias noticias para
destacar un país que al principio de la
pandemia destacaba a nivel internacional
por el manejo que le estaba dando a la
crisis vamos a conocer entonces más
detalles del panorama allí con cary nada
más desde punta del este- en el
departamento de maldonado karina uruguay
anunció recientemente que va a levantar
las restricciones que había una
controversia que hubo incluso por el
cierre de las fronteras aislaron el país
ya no van a volver a abrirse qué implica
esto para la lucha contra el kobe 19 y
como recibieron el anuncio sobre todo en
el sector turístico
así es santiago uruguay abrió
parcialmente sus fronteras permitiendo
el ingreso de uruguayos y de extranjeros
residentes también hay algunas
excepciones dentro de este marco pero
las tienen que aprobar presidencia de la
república uruguay cerró totalmente sus
fronteras tratando de disminuir el
contagio de kobe 19 en vísperas de las
fiestas de navidad y fin de año también
porque nos encontramos aquí en plena
temporada de verano tú mencionabas
cuáles han sido las reacciones
justamente en el sector turístico muchos
esperaban que la reapertura fuera un
poco más flexible incluso se conversó
mucho se analizó el tema de un pasaporte
sanitario el gobierno dijo que
continuará analizando lo mismo también
es un reclamo de propietarios en su
mayoría argentinos que tienen
propiedades en la costa uruguaya eso por
el momento no
ser autorizado karina también destacado
el anuncio que hizo el presidente luis
lacalle pou anunció que compró varios
lotes de vacunas para comenzar el plan
de inmunización nacional que detalles
hay sobre este plan de inmunización de
que vacunas estamos hablando y cómo va a
ser ese plan para inocular a los 3.4
millones de habitantes que tiene la
república oriental
exactamente el gobierno uruguayo informó
que la vacunación va a ser voluntaria
incluso le van a pedir a las personas
que firmen un consentimiento indicando
que conocen los posibles efectos
secundarios de las vacunas algo muy
diferente a lo que es el plan regular de
vacunación en uruguay donde la
vacunación es obligatoria y no se firma
ningún tipo de consentimiento el
gobierno informó que ya compró más de
3.800.000 dosis de los laboratorios
facer y sinovac y que también espera un
millón y medio de dosis del plan
kóvacs las primeras personas en recibir
no serán personal de salud quienes
trabajen en geriátricos y también en
educación 165 mil personas se esperan
está planificado que reciban sus
primeras dosis en las últimas semanas de
febrero los primeros días de marzo
karina pregunta transversal para todos
los corresponsales para actualizarnos
cómo está la situación en cada país cómo
está uruguay en términos de contagios de
fallecidos ya tenemos detalles
que la zona de ribera en el norte del
país ya no es zona roja de contagio y ha
mejorado la situación allí
exactamente no solamente el departamento
de ribera sino que uruguay también salió
de zona roja todo el país estuvo en este
índice rojo de harvard durante varios
días durante el mes de diciembre
afortunadamente no es la realidad en
este momento pero como todo en relación
a la pandemia es algo que cambia un
momento a momento pero si en los últimos
días el índice de nuevos contagios ha
descendido en estos momentos hay unos
5.900 casos activos y se deben lamentar
unos 476 fallecidos
y ahora lo que está ocurriendo es que
muchos uruguayos están retornando a la
capital del país luego de sus vacaciones
en la costa de uruguay y también los
niños están afrontando para la vuelta a
clases que según indicó el gobierno de
acuerdo a la situación actual de la
pandemia las clases van a ser
obligatorias y presenciales
karina muchas gracias por este reporte
desde la ciudad de punta del este en la
costa uruguaya nos vamos ahora hasta
perú allí las autoridades anunciaron que
el 9 de febrero llegará el primer lote
de vacunas a este país a este país allí
hay muchas expectativas en torno a este
lote de vacunación que va a llegar a
este país porque la segunda ola de
contagio está causando estragos
esperamos
eduardo core y está preocupado su suegro
se encuentra grave y no puede internarlo
en un hospital 23 pacientes que están
espera de cambio
y uno debe ser era mi suelo que estaba
ahí
aquí estás abandonasen la cambia en el
país están los pacientes los hospitales
del perú están desbordados por pacientes
el joven 19 que en medio de esta crisis
los médicos llevan más de dos semanas de
huelga indefinida exigen mayor inversión
en el sector salud en el gremio el
sector está colapsando pero ha puesto al
borde de un colapso queda un poquito
margen para poder reaccionar como
sistema sanitario en este en esta
segunda ola y es el colapso afecta no
solo la falta de camas en salas críticas
sino el recurso humano el presidente
francisco se haga así ha ordenado el
retorno a la cuarentena en 10 regiones
del perú y aseguró que se mejorará la
atención de la emergencia sanitaria
estamos ampliando el número de camas uci
se han incorporado 196 camas en las
últimas dos semanas y se añadirán 350
más en las próximas dos semanas para los
ciudadanos en busca del oxígeno que
pueda salvar a sus familiares
la promesa es el presidente se haga así
suenan como palabras vacías como muchos
cristian valiente tuvo que ausentarse de
su trabajo
buscar el gas medicinal que su madre de
80 años necesita para respirar por eso
estamos desesperados viviendo de
diferentes distritos para conseguir eso
que lo más primordial
tras tres días de espera y un largo
viaje a las afueras de nima cristian
retorna a su hogar él espera no
contagiarse de el coronavirus para
seguir luchando por la vida de su madre
hasta aquí este resumen de france el 24
hasta aquí este episodio de kobe 19 la
semana en américa esta fue nuestra
selección de las noticias más destacadas
a lo largo de estos siete días usted
puede ver otra vez este programa en
france24 punto com y también en nuestro
canal de youtube nosotros nos vemos la
próxima semana siga con france24
[Música]